so
most of modern life all our diseases are
diseases of abundance
not diseases of scarcity right old times
i may have starved
uh you know old times if i got sugar
that was a wonderful thing i should have
eaten all the sugar to get my hands on
if i got in a piece of news or gossip
that was interesting data that would
have helped my life and moved me forward
if i'd gotten some brief amount of
entertainment whether through video
games or magazines or whatever that
would have been good
now it's all disease of abundance we are
over exposed to everything
the human brain is not designed to
absorb
all of the world's breaking news 24 7
emergencies
injected straight into your skull with
clickbait headline news
if you pay attention to that stuff even
if you're well meaning
even if your sound of mind and body it
will eventually drive you insane
this goes back to clockwork orange where
he's you know has his eyes opened up
he's forced to watch the news
but i think that's what's happening
right now because these are addictive
right
twitter facebook instagram these are
weaponized you have
social statisticians and scientists and
researchers and people in lab coats
literally
best minds of our generation figuring
out how to addict you to the news
yes and if you fall for it if you get
addicted your brain will get destroyed
and i think this is the modern struggle
right the modern struggle so the ancient
struggle used to be the tribal struggle
you had your tribe of friends and family
you had your religion you had your
country you had your loyalty you had
your nationality
at least you had meaning and support but
now you would struggle against other
tribes
modern life we're so free everything's
become atomized we stand alone you live
in your apartment alone you live in your
house alone your parents don't live
nearby your friends don't live nearby
you don't have any tribal meaning you
don't believe in religion anymore you
don't believe in country anymore it's
fine you got a lot of freedom it's
fantastic
but now when they come to attack you
you're alone and you can't resist so how
do they attack you it's all well-meaning
i don't fault capitalism i love
capitalism but
look at how it happens social media
they've
massaged all the mechanisms to addict
you like a
skinner's pigeon or a rat who's just
gonna click click click click click
can't put the phone down
the food they've taken sugar and they've
weaponized it they've put it into
all these different forms and varieties
that you can't resist eating
drugs right they've taken
pharmaceuticals and plants and they've
synthesized them they've grown them in
such a way that you can't you get
addicted you can't put them down
porn right if you're a young male you
wander on the internet
it'll like sap away your libido and
you're not going out in real life
society anymore because you've got
this incredibly stimulating stuff coming
at you video games another way to addict
people
so you have this you have entire
large factories of people that are
working to addict you to these things
and you stand alone
so the modern struggle as an individual
is learning how to resist these things
in the first place drawing your own
boundaries and there's no one there to
help you